Gary you keep talking about investing in
startups but I don't have twenty five
thousand dollars in fact I'm six
thousand in debt and I have ninety three
dollars in my bank account what do I do
and you know you're getting this
constantly thousands of people tens of
thousands of people emailing me and at
some point [__] I gotta do something and
I was like all right I'm gonna show them
what I did when I had ninety three
dollars I garage sailed and sold stuff
on eBay you got me into this man you say
in my life thank you bro makes me happy
me and my wife started doing this a
couple of months ago look at that number
my man what did you start with you
started with 100 bucks my man
husband and I lost our means of
employment over covid and it was
sneakers and so that got us through the
the hump there so
foreign